字幕: Yumika Amano
校正: Ayana Ishiyama
自分の中で何かが変わった
そんな経験をしたことはありますか
あるという方 それはどんな時でしたか
人が変わる時
そこには さまざまなきっかけがあります
今回は 私が変わるきっかけとなった
お話をご紹介いたします
私は小学生のころ 引っ込み思案で
人前に出ると すぐ顔が赤くなって
よく風邪をひいて スポーツが苦手
そんな子どもでした
体育のソフトボール投げのとき 私はクラス最下位で
恥ずかしい思いをしたことを覚えています
自分に自信がありませんでした
そんな私にも 得意なことがありました
それは 勉強すること
何か ものを覚えるということです
当時の私は思いました
もっと もっと 勉強したら
難しいことがわかるようになって
海外の人とも 話ができて
周りから 「すごい」 と思われるような
そんな人間になれるかもしれない
つまり 私は
「勉強することで自分を変えられる」
と 感じていたのです
そのためには
人と同じことをするだけではだめだと思いました
小学６年生になった私は
受験をして入る中学校は
きっと他の中学校とは違って
何か難しいことを習うに違いない
そう考え 母に頼んで
中学受験をさせてもらいました
そして無事合格し 進学しました
自分にとって最もよい選択はなにか
自分でそれを考えた結果です
中学３年生になった私は
もっと具体的に
なりたい自分をイメージするようになりました
将来は 高度な知識が要求されて
海外との関わりがあって
イメージがかっこよくて
社会に貢献できる そんな仕事がしたい
当時の私が辿りついた答えは
「外交官になる」 ということでした
私は真剣でした
外交官になるのは とても難しいことです
その高いハードルのクリアのために
自分にとって最善の進路はなんだろう
考え出した結論は
ランクの高い高校に入って
猛勉強して
そして 日本の最高学府と言われる
東京大学に入学する というものでした
反対する家族に無理を言って
当時 旭川に住んでいた私は
札幌南高校を受験
そして 無事合格することができました
それからの私は
受験勉強のことしか 頭にありませんでした
高校１年生の夏から
毎日のように予備校に通い
教室が閉まるまで勉強して帰宅しました
なんとしても
自分の目標に到達したかったのです
一方で 友達とのコミュニケーション
つきあいには
あまり積極的ではありませんでした
そして 迎えた高校３年生の２月
私は東京大学を受験しました
結果は不合格でした
私は非常に落ち込みました
自分の能力の低さを痛感しました
頭では これは想定済みの結果だ
落ち込んでいる場合ではない
一刻も早く 来年に向けて準備を再開するべきだ
と 分かっていたのに
感情がそれに追いついていきませんでした
描いていた将来像が音を立てて崩れ
私は 一日中
こう締めつけられるように胸が苦しく
何も手につかない
といったような状態が続きました
この苦しさをなんとかしたい
そう思った私は
次第に死を意識するようになりました
「どうやって死のうか」
「最も苦しくない方法はなんだろう」
自殺の参考になるような本を探しました
そんな時 ある本の帯に書かれていた
「世界 一周しちゃえば？」という言葉に魅かれ
私はその本を読み 決めました
「世界 一周しよう」
「やりたいことをやってお金がなくなったら
そこで死んでしまおう」
イギリス行きのチケットを購入し
東京のビジネスホテルを予約した私は
携帯電話の電源を切り
バックパックを背負い
誰にも伝えることなく こっそり家を出ました
東京のホテルにチェックインし
イギリスへの出発を翌日にひかえ
私は 眠りにつきました
翌朝 目を覚ました私は驚きました
なんと 飛行機の出発時刻が過ぎているでは
ありませんか
（笑）
私は困りました
「どうしよう もう飛行機には乗れない」
「何日もホテルに滞在していたら
旅のお金がなくなってしまう」
困った私は
東京の 板谷君という友人に 電話をかけ
泊めてくれるよう頼みました
私は 彼の家に 居候させてもらいながら
旅の資金を増やそうと思い
アルバイトをすることにしました
彼と２ヶ月間 共に生活をして
さすがに彼に申し訳ないなと 思った私は
彼の家を出て
ホテルで住み込みのアルバイトを始めました
そんな生活を続けているうちに
ふと気づきました
「あれ 苦しくない」
同時に 私はアルバイトよりも
何か自分のスキルを活かしてする仕事の方が
好きなのではないかと考えるようになりました
その思いは 日に日に強くなっていくばかりです
再度勉強したいと思った私は
今度はアメリカへ留学し
一般教養を学びました
そして より専門的な勉強をしたい
という思いから帰国し
現在は 大学でITの勉強をしています
なぜ 希望を見失っていた人生において
もう一度がんばろうと思えたのか
それは 板谷君がいてくれたからに他なりません
私が何を考え
何を決断しようとも
それをありのまま受け入れてくれるだろうと
信頼を寄せることができた友人
それが彼でした
彼は感動的な 悩みがふきとんでしまうような
奇跡の言葉をかけてくれたわけではありません
ただ まるで昔に戻ったような気持ちで
悩みながらも 楽しく過ごした
彼との２ヶ月が
私を変えたのです
私を救ってくれたのは 親友の板谷君でした
さて 昨年 私の通う北海道情報大学で
TEDxイベント TEDxHIU が開催され
私はスピーカーとして登壇しました
登壇の依頼をいただいた時
「私に話せることなんて何もない」 と思い
引き受けようかどうか 非常に悩みました
しかし 先ほどお話したような 私の経験や
当時考えていたこと 感じていたことが
もしかしたら 誰かの役に立つかもしれない
そう思い 引き受けることにしました
イベント当日まで 私は
私のスピーチをよりよいものにすることだけに
集中していました
内容を練り
英語で原稿を書き
締切と プレッシャーに追われ
練習と リハーサルを繰り返し
「大変なことを引き受けてしまった」
と思いながら 準備を進めました
そしてむかえた当日
私は無事スピーチをすることができました
安堵感と達成感を感じました
イベントの後 TEDxHIUを作り上げた
チームメンバー全員が集まって
イベントの振り返りが行われました
私もそこに同席したのですが
私にとっては
そこで初めてお会いする方がほとんどでした
会場やフライヤーをデザインするチーム
スピーカーをサポートするチーム
広報・イベントを担当するチーム
そして 私にアドバイスと励ましを下さった方々
その方々のコメントを聞いて 初めて気づきました
私の 私以外の
私の知らないところで 一生懸命頑張っていた人達の
その苦労がなければ
このイベントは そして私のスピーチは
そもそも成立しえなかったのだと
それと同時に 私もスピーカーとしての
自分の役割を果たすことによって
その方々に貢献することができた
そう感じたとき 何とも言えない嬉しさが
こみあげてくるのが分かりました
私に自分の視野の狭さと
協力して共通の目標へと向かう
素晴らしさを教えてくれたのは
TEDxHIUの皆さんでした
私は以前
他人への感謝の気持ちというものを
あまり持たない人間だったと思います
何事も自分でどうするべきなのか考え
そして自分で決断してきた
そう感じていました
しかし 私は気づきました
自分は自分ひとりの力だけでは変えられない
誰か他の人の存在が必要なのだと
希望を見失っていたとき
私に もう一度立ち上がる力をくれたのは
親友の板谷君でした
私に自分の視野の狭さと
チームの素晴らしさを教えてくれたのは
TEDxHIUの皆さんでした
自分ひとりでは決して
気づくことができなかったことだと思います
私を変えてくれた 大勢の人に
とても感謝しています
今 私には やりたいことがあります
まずは自分のスキルをより一層高めること
そのスキルを活かして
共通の目標を持つ仲間と
共に何かを成し遂げたい
そして 人が私を変え 助けてくれたように
私も誰かの助けになりたい ということです
皆さんはどうでしょうか
私の提案は３つです
もしあなたが何かに悩んでいるなら
誰かに声をかけてみてください
もし 仲間を募っている人がいたら
そこに飛び込んでみてください
もし あなたに 何かやりたいことがあるなら
周りに声をかけてみてください
きっと 誰かが あなたに変化をもたらし
また あなたが 誰かに変化をもたらすはずです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）